vitae schtick values good food he loves
cooking for himself and for others but
when he was a child he was never sure if
there would be enough food then I
wouldn't get breakfast if I had wet the
bed I wet my bed for a long long time oh
so I was hungry for a long time old yah
Tanaka Senora talita the Swiss
authorities deemed xparent social
outcasts they took him and placed him in
a foster family there he had no other
choice than to work on the fields to
earn his living at the tender age of
five he had become one of thousands of
so-called contract children the house
that stood were vitae grew up has been
torn down but it never felt like home to
him anyway we are taught often me unki
mine so we weren't allowed to sit at the
table where everybody else was eating um
church tiresome talk we always had to
eat standing by the sink stayin always
Dantas is entire naman amid the
authorities took children from poor
families in particular since 1800 they
were traded on markets like little
slaves back then Switzerland was a poor
agricultural country and the children
were welcomed labourers they were given
to those farmers demanding the lowest
child support from the authorities and
were then put to work all day long until
the age of 16
the orbit work was considered an
educational tool feelin play give about
many foster families with farmers and
we're also glad to have these children
as laborers in many cases they exploited
them abstinence for many years these
contract children remained silent their
stories were considered at odds with the
images wits erlend as a successful and
orderly country now a former children's
home has been turned into a place of
remembrance not by the state but by a
Swiss businessman who suffered here
himself Korea teammate the nom de pollo
mean Amish flu taquito gido flu has
initiated a political campaign seeking
justice for the former contract children
he's already won a small victory
Switzerland's upper chamber has decided
that they will receive a compensation of
20,000 euros this wouldn't have been
possible without flurries powerful
campaign or his wealth he coughed he's a
Patou the former contract children were
weak they didn't have a lobbying so they
couldn't make themselves heard he making
bought and Wadena sure the media did
report about them but you always need
money to make your cause widely known
that's for sure call there were some
100,000 contract children throughout
Switzerland many were placed in foster
homes and then moved to strict
children's homes they never learned what
it meant to fight for their rights and
their parents weren't around to support
them or they didn't care
there's a throne ines malish doors you
could walk up a small lane and see the
train station from there we would head
up there to see if our parents were
coming to calm did not do that my
parents never showed up one day it was
brutal oh yah das war doll after decades
of silence this tragedy is only
gradually being worked through but ash
deck now speaks openly about his ordeals
his accounts have become part of an
archive documenting the experiences of
contract children like him disk ed
Malloy day there are always those people
who don't want to confront the past
shmeh utica scopic it's a dark and
painful chapter in Swiss history got
people of it glad but I'm convinced one
should properly no one's history in
order to know where you stand with our
apron off to think and when to be able
to move forward meanwhile better stack
has come to enjoy life he isn't seeking
revenge but he can't forgive either he
can't forget his childhood which was
defined by hate and violence was was
many knew what was going on but nobody
cared to look many didn't believe us
either I speak of us because there were
many others like me no one ever believed
us it was optimal one now at 70 he'll
receive 20,000 euros in what he says is
a recognition of his suffering he
doesn't like the word compensation
because nothing he says could ever make
the pain he experienced undone